when you're Adam Levine you don't have  to have a game  let me tell you you can be a dweeb when  you're Adam Levine if you're that much  of a dweeb in the DMS can you imagine  how much of a dweeb you are when you  actually get into that bedroom it's all  I'm gonna say if you're that Blown Away  guys that actually have game in the  bedroom aren't Blown Away by like cheeks  on Instagram they're not like oh my God  that booty they don't act like that they  don't think about it guys that have game  in the bedroom have some composure and  some impulse control they're not going  to salivate all over everything that  walks on two feet all around no they're  not gonna do that all over Instagram